Ja.
Ein Quanten-circuit ist die Werteinheit
für dein Unternehmen – das qubit ist die Informationseinheit,
aber ein circuit ist die Recheneinheit.
Lass uns also verstehen, was ein Quanten-circuit ist,
und seinen Aufbau betrachten.
So sieht ein Quanten-circuit aus –
er setzt sich aus Teilen zusammen: Die qubits
werden durch diese horizontalen Linien dargestellt. In diesem Fall zeigen wir
einen circuit mit vier qubits, die du hier
siehst. Die gates sind
das Mittel, um die qubits zu steuern,
und du liest die gates von links nach rechts.
Die Einzel-qubit-gates können entweder
Einzel-qubit-gates oder Multi-qubit-gates sein.
Du siehst dort das kontrollierte gate –
das ist dasjenige mit der Linie zwischen zwei der qubits.
Dort findet die Verschränkungsoperation statt.
Und schließlich hast du die Messung und den klassischen Ausgang.
Sehr wichtig: Du führst einen circuit viele Male aus,
um das Ergebnis zu erhalten – mit dem Begriff „Shots".
Ein Shot-Zähler gibt an, wie oft
du eine Berechnung wiederholen musst, um das Ergebnis zu erhalten.
Nun,
wie sehen sie aus?
Lass uns anschauen, wie ein Zwei-qubit-circuit aussieht –
das war das Bild von vorhin, mit der Einführung einer Phasenänderung.
Ich habe vorhin eine Operation gezeigt, die diese Rotation durchführt
und es ermöglicht, diese Interferenzoperation auszuführen.
Lass uns also einen klassischen circuit
mit einem Quanten-circuit vergleichen. Bei einem klassischen circuit
siehst du keine blauen Töne, richtig?
Keine Rotationen – alles hier ist pink.
Du hast die einzelnen Zustände,
die in diesen gates wie Fenster wirken.
Aber schau, welch ein Kontrast sich zeigt,
wenn wir tatsächlich einen Quanten-circuit implementieren.
Das sind die echten circuits, die wir in unseren Quantencomputern ausführen –
die du auch selbst ausprobieren kannst.
Die circuits, die wir erstellen,
erzeugen durch die Kombination der gates
die volle komplexe Amplitudenstruktur,
die ich dir vorhin gezeigt habe.
Warum ist das wichtig?
Weil wir jetzt diese komplexen Beziehungen
zwischen den qubits in Bezug auf Phasen
und Verschränkung erzeugen können, und durch den Messvorgang
können wir diese enorme Menge
an Berechnung, die intern stattfindet, auf
eine wichtige Antwort reduzieren.
Und so gelangen wir schließlich
zur Antwort. Wenn wir sie nebeneinanderstellen, kannst du visuell
erkennen, dass ein klassischer circuit
niemals den riesigen Rechenraum ausschöpfen kann,
den ein Quanten-circuit bietet.
Die Visualisierungen geben dir ein Gespür
für den Reichtum, mit dem wir auf diesen großen Zustandsraum zugreifen können.
Das Schöne daran ist, dass wir
viele Klassen von circuits haben können,
die verschiedene Aufgaben erfüllen.
Zum Beispiel ist dies ein circuit,
der dafür entwickelt wurde, finanzielle Risiken zu modellieren.
Hier ist ein Beispiel für einen circuit,
der für Such- und Optimierungsprobleme eingesetzt wird.
Und hier ist ein Beispiel für einen circuit, der verwendet wird, um
ein Molekül zu simulieren. Eine wichtige
Erkenntnis: Du kannst verschiedene circuits
für verschiedene Anwendungen entwerfen.
Die circuits, die wir entwerfen, werden dann
in Software abgebildet und dort gespeichert.
In unserem Fall halten wir sie in Qiskit fest,
unserem Open-Source-Entwicklungskit für Quantencomputing.
Dies ist eines der am weitesten verbreiteten
Software-Frameworks für Quantencomputing.
Und du kannst dir vorstellen,
Bibliotheken von circuits aufzubauen, die in
klassische Programme eingebettet werden und so das Beste aus klassischer Programmierung
und das Beste aus Quantenleistung vereinen.